الاطفال وبقدر ما كانوا الاوفر حظا
بالنجاه من تحت انقاذ الزلزال المدمر
بتركيا اصبحوا اليوم الفئه الاكثر تضررا
من صدمه الكارثه اثار الصدمه علقت في
اذهانهم فصارت مضمونه لرسومات تخطها
اناملهم
التي تحتوي على العاب وكتب للمطالعه
والرسم ونؤمن لهم الطعام كذلك وكما تعلمون
المدارس مغلقه في الولايات المتضرره
والاطفال يحتاجون الى الرعايه والتعليم
تشير التقديرات الاوليه الى تضرر اكثر من
مليوني طفل من الزلزال في تركيا فيما تحذر
منظمه اليونيسيف الامميه من تبعات ذلك
عليهم مثل هذه الفضاءات المخصصه للاطفال
وفي هذا التوقيت بالذات ستجنب لا محاله
مالات غير محموده لهذه الفئه التي عاشت
هول كارثه الزلزال المدمر دعم نفسي
ومرافقه بمختلف الانشطه قد تعيد لهم وهج
الحياه من جديد عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
هاتاي جنوب تركيا